[Music]
let's finish up Disney cember with
arguably the biggest Marvel movie to
date Avengers infinity war this film has
been so built up it's crazy and
surprisingly enough it isn't just from
the advertising since the first Avengers
movie where Thanos was revealed they've
been hyping up his appearance in
practically every other flick Thanos is
coming fan else's coming he's gonna be
here soon it got to a point where it was
actually comical to a point where was
almost annoying people start to say
there's no way they're gonna live up to
the hype they're building up we're sick
of hearing fan OSes coming fan OHS is
coming just do something with them
already you know what Thanos doesn't
even look that grave he just looks like
a big purple blob monster who's gonna do
I don't know smile so even though there
was a lot of excitement around this
movie there was a lot of speculation too
but amazingly the part of the movie
everybody thought would be the weakest
link is the strongest part Josh Brolin
as Thanos not only looks amazing with
this incredible motion capture but he
has to be hands down the best Marvel
villain out of any of these movies after
just being teased with snippets of him
in the other films this is entirely his
movie it's his story why is he doing
this how is he doing this what's going
through his mind what does he care about
what's he going to do next he's actually
so interesting the Avengers are almost
distracting and those are incredibly
charming characters the plot o attempt
to sum up there is a ton going on is
that fan oohs has taken over Thor and
Loki ship destroyed everybody on it
which kind of sucks Thor Ragnarok was
kind of a no reason and even ends up
beating the shit out of the Hulk the
Hulk goddamn
Hulk lands on earth though and lets him
know that Thanos is coming fano sends
out his minions to look for the rest of
the Infinity stones you see if he gets
all the Infinity stones and puts him on
his Infinity Gauntlet he can fulfill his
ultimate goal of wiping out half of
humanity his thought is whenever a
population is getting too big they
become too dangerous so wiping out half
of them will bring balance back it
doesn't even matter who they are it's
just half he did this before with
gamora's people and he actually ended up
raising her she not surprisingly resents
him quite a bit and does everything in
her power to stop him but he's
two cunning and two manipulative to be
defeated the more the Avengers try to
get together ironically the more they
get split up the Infinity stones are
spread out far across the galaxy so that
means a lot of them have to go to
different places to try and get them can
they reach them in time and stop Thanos
before he wipes out half of the human
race I'm not gonna give away the ending
but prepare for your kids to be scarred
for life
the funny thing about infinity war is
that what I usually see as cons in a
movie I actually see as pros in this one
the characters are not given much
introduction there's not even that much
sitting down and talking about their
feelings or emotions or anything like
that they're just kind of running into
the action but here's the thing we
already know these characters we've had
movie upon movie upon movie finding out
about these characters so when you do
see them together you don't just want
Captain America talking about himself or
star-lord talking about himself you want
to see them interact off each other and
that's exactly what we get
Iron Man at Doctor Strange have been
called very similar so they of course
don't get along star-lord and Thor are
both cocky fighters so they obviously
try to one-up each other
spider-man is always looking for Tony
Stark's approval so they have kind of a
father-son relationship while they're
constantly fighting and going from place
to place they are still making
connections and they're using just the
right choice words to establish
themselves and their relationships as
incredibly likable even when they don't
get along there's an incredible charm to
them in most action movies when
characters get together and bicker it
feels lame it's like those stupid buddy
cop movies or those dumbass romantic
comedies where they just complain the
whole time and yet somehow they get
along but here there's so well set up
you love when they don't get along
they're funny they're quips are
wonderful and you like seeing how they
actually do kind of come together it got
to a point where even the smallest
cameos got a cheer from everybody
because they knew they were gonna be
done right even if they didn't say much
or too much you knew that was them they
were there they were interacting with
everybody they were helping out the
universe feel so defined the only part
that drags a little as there's a scene
where Thor has to meet up with this
giant played very cleverly by Peter
Dinklage it's not just because that's a
little person playing a big person
because his dimensions are different it
isn't just taking an average-sized
person and making him bigger
Peter Dinklage has a very distinct
uniquely J body so to make that larger
gives a visual and a movement we hadn't
really seen before out of a giant but it
goes on way too long every single time
it cut back to on that this weird gait
and trying to move all these little
technical gadgets around it I just
didn't care maybe because the action
here wasn't very interesting and what
they were talking about was very
interesting but everywhere else the
dialogue and the action are fantastic
again especially from Thanos I can't
believe how much they won me over with
this character I was so ready to not
like the motion capture why can't they
just do practical effects I was so ready
to be bored by him now you built him up
too long now we're not interested but he
really was the best part somehow
supplying both the Menace and the heart
of the movie what can I say the weight
was worth it
infinity war is a big movie that has a
lot of big effects and a lot of big
battles and a lot of big characters and
a lot of big story it's the kind of
movie where you want a lot going on it's
the kind of movie where you want a lot
of things blowing up and people looking
pained and going from one place to
another and it can do that because it's
had so many films building up to it this
was a gamble that definitely paid off
just when you're starting to get tired
of the Marvel formula and you're kind of
looking for something different they
upped their game like they usually do
they seem to know just want to mix it up
a little bit more and exactly how to mix
it up while still seeming familiar it's
the same characters with brand new
challenges and folks that's it for this
year's Disney Center I know I had a lot
to get through and I probably didn't get
to everything I wanted to I'll keep
watching and maybe you'll see him in the
near future as always Disney for so many
years has been pushing the envelope of
what's creative what's important what's
childlike and what's adult it's hard to
combine all those things in one but
somehow Disney still ends up doing it as
long as they keep putting out a ton of
material I'll always be there to talk
about and as long as you're always there
to view it I will always consider myself
a lucky critic thank you for watching
and I'll see you at next year's Disney
supper
you